and it realized at the time that it was
going to turn into this essentially soap
opera that's pretty much what it was and
that we were gonna be that it was just
gonna turn into what it turned into it
was just a wild crazy time but it was
fun here's the killer later
it was a fun job it was essentially a
job they knew I would react and that's
what I did could you imagine what your
life would be like if there was social
media around when the show with other
wasn't I would have been in a lot more
trouble than I was
hi i'm jabari Oh No thank God I didn't
join social we didn't area under the
hills she's a man-eater she's a
boyfriend stealer who do you plan on
happen enoughness does little craziness
maybe he's doing it kiss me you know
Audrina's gonna be coming after oh of
course I haven't gone back in Washington
but one day hope you never know I mean I
well MTV played them on TV I think it
was two summers ago and my husband Jay
had them on when I came home one time
and that was it's kind of brutal for me
to sit through but is it a little bit if
I was so obnoxious but I'm like I just
letting your baby daughter yeah I'm like
different time in my life I'm sure